Speaker 1: Radical Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor GREENE. I've got to give her
credit. She's trying to do something clever. She's
trying it. It's totally dishonest. It's completely
disgusting. It's also totally predictable.
But it is clever, which is she is trying to
very casually abandon the completely extreme and
delusional elements that she previously associated
with or still did. Still does, as far as we know,
including the Q and on stuff and the most extreme
elements of MAGA and just sort of say, you know,
I kind of got sucked into stuff, but like I voted
for Kevin McCarthy, now I'm in, I'm part of the
Republican establishment and I'm going to be on
committees and it's all going to be great. And
the reason she is doing this is exactly what
I just said. She doesn't want to be the extreme
cartoon anymore. She wants to be taken seriously
as a committee member in good standing right
up there with Kevin McCarthy, with the speaker
of the House and adjacent to power. Part of this
rewriting of history started in an interview on
Fox News over the weekend where when Howard KURTZ
asked her about some of her previous, you know,
associations, affiliations, etc., she basically
just writes it off and says, oh, you know,
I got sucked into some stuff on the Internet.
Speaker 2: Yeah. And just to deal with one bit
of history, the Democrats stripped you of
your committee assignments after you did.
That was Raw Politics. But in fairness, didn't
you also say around that period that you had
been a follower of Q and on conspiracy
theories and you had we thought this and
you were no longer influenced by the group?
Speaker 3: Well, like a lot of people today,
I had easily gotten sucked into some things
I'd seen on the Internet, but that was dealt
with quickly early on. I never campaigned
on those things. That was not something I
believed in. That's not what I ran for Congress
on. So those are so far in the past. All right.
Speaker 2: You tweeted.
Speaker 1: This is a bald faced attempt
or a bald faced attempt. I go with both.
I like both to try to excuse and eliminate
and remove her record, which includes,
she said, crazy anti-Semitic things.
She was arguing that the Trump rioters
from January six should just be released,
that they're political prisoners, that they are
they're martyrs of some kind. She taunted a kid
who is traumatized by gun violence. She went to an
event organized by and at which white supremacist
Nick Fuentes spoke and then said, I don't know
anything about it. She accused Nancy Pelosi of
treason, Jewish space, lasers on and on and on
and on and on. And now she wants to go. And I saw
some stuff on the Internet. A lot of people what
happens to a lot of people. But I didn't run on
that stuff. I didn't run on that stuff. The reason
she's doing it is that now that they're in power,
she needs a different image. Support the speaker.
Get onto committees. Be taken seriously as a
stateswoman of some kind. The problem is you
shouldn't be able to. And hopefully she won't
be able to just write off entire swaths of her
history. Another clip I'm going to play for you.
Howard KURTZ says, you know, a lot of the people
backing McCarthy didn't want to certify the
election. Is that still important to the base?
And she goes, Absolutely. Election denialism, she
says, is now mainstream Republican Party do that.
Speaker 2: When things got heated. You said this
about Congressman Schiff, Roy of Texas. He
refused to object on January six. That's not
what our base wanted. So a lot of the
people who are backing Kevin McCarthy
also didn't vote to certify the Electoral
College results for Joe Biden. Do you think
that's an important thing to base even today?
Speaker 3: Oh, it's very important. What I was
pointing out is the same people that conservatives
were holding up in high esteem don't necessarily
have those voting records while they're at
the same time criticizing Kevin McCarthy,
who does. Kevin McCarthy did object on
January six, and he's been a top target
of the Democrats and the judiciary so.
Speaker 2: Vehemently that Joe Biden
is a legitimately elected president.
Speaker 3: Of course, Joe Biden is the
president. That's always a silly question.
Speaker 2: Okay. I'm trying to
be silly. I was trying to.
Speaker 1: Well, she didn't
answer the question. The question was, is he a
legitimately elected president? And she says,
of course he's the president. So even though she
is trying really hard to distance from. Q and on
and distance from the conspiracy theories and
whatever, when it came down to it right there,
she answered about Biden being a legitimate
president the way they love doing it,
which is by saying he is the president, which
is a total cop out. And she insists that now
election denialism is part of the base of the
Republican Party. Is it a big enough base for
them to win in 24? We don't know. Okay. One more
clip from this completely deranged interview.
She says that a lot of the holdouts from the
speaker vote just wanted attention, which when
I think of congresspeople who want attention
at. My mind first goes to Marjorie Taylor
GREENE But now she says others wanted attention.
Speaker 3: Most important thing that every single
member has is their voting card. There's only 222
Republicans, and we need to 18 to pass anything.
That's where the magic happens. And so the big
fight that happened this week, I think that a
lot of it was really unnecessary and just a bunch
of fanfare that helps popularity on the Internet
but doesn't produce results. Now we have a speaker
that we can produce results with, and we have to
do that by coming together to get to 18. That's
where our power lies. And so with this rules
package, let's be very real. We've got a Biden
White House. We have a Democrat controlled Senate,
and we got to get to to 18 to accomplish anything.
Speaker 2: Right. Ultimately, in Washington,
it's about the math.
Speaker 1: They just wanted
attention. It was because they wanted to get
popular on the Internet, which is the epitome
of Marjorie Taylor. GREENE So let's go back to
the beginning. It's dishonest. It's absurd. It's
pathetic what she's doing. But it just might
work. She really might be able to rewrite and
remake her image now that they are in control.
And that's a very scary thing to think about